I think a much more troubling a result
of this election was the ballot
initiative in Arkansas you know I was
speaking with some some gay friends of
mine and this was a ballot initiative
that that basically forbade or now for
bathes by law single people from
adopting children in Arkansas so you
have to be married in a traditional
marriage in order to be able to adopt
children and this was something that for
me was very troubling it was troubling
for a host of reasons one is the energy
as I mentioned before the energy behind
the passage of this ballot initiative by
pro-family groups and conservative
groups in Arkansas used this equation of
homosexuality and pedophilia to drive
people to the polls to vote in favor of
denying single people and that means gay
and lesbian people because gay and
lesbian people can't be by law and
Arkansas part of a traditional marriage
and so it effectively denies them the
right to adopt children so that any gay
or lesbian person in the state of
Arkansas has now been denied the right
to adopt and raise children and these
are these include foster children who
are languishing in foster homes you can
imagine what the state of foster care
must be a state like in a depressed
state like Arkansas it's not good in any
state it's certainly I'm sure it's not
very good in Arkansas either this to me
is a very troubling step backwards it
brings up all of those kind of historic
stigmas that we're still dealing with
and fighting against the LGBT community
so for me that ballot initiative in
Arkansas was far more insidious and far
more for me a sign that we have not made
enough progress and that we may in fact
be taking a step backward then the prop
8 vote because at the end of the day the
prop 8 vote was the gay marriage
resolution was was closer this time
around than it had been previously in
California there's been movement in the
direction of progress in the issue of
marriage
the issue of marriage is a very sticky
one I personally though I relish my
right to get married to my partner if I
so choose in Massachusetts and looks
like that's also going to happen in New
York very soon it certainly happened all
throughout New England with the
exception of Rhode Island and you know I
relished that right I'm happy to have it
I'm grateful to people who have
struggled to earn that right in the
states where we've earned it but I don't
think that the marriage issue
strategically is the best thing to put
at the forefront of our movement and I
think there has been among some leaders
in the LGBT movement an overemphasis on
marriage and I think that that is it
there are two problems with that one is
that marriage is the most sacred of
institutions right i mean it culturally
speaking and the public imagination Pete
most people despite the fact that we're
fifty percent divorce rate among
straight married couples we raise
marriage to a sort of pedestal that we
don't raise any other kind of
relationship to and I think that has a
lot of reasons for that historically but
when you seek to become kind of fully
integrated and have the full rights of
marriage you're going to you know it's
like kicking a kicking a bee's nest or a
kicking a hornet's nest and that's what
the LGBT community has done that's not
to say that you shouldn't kick Hornets
nests I think that you know we wouldn't
be any none of us would be anywhere if
we didn't kick a few hornet's nest but
at the end of the day we have to
understand it when you kick a hornet's
nest are going to be Hornets right and
you're going to get stung and I sound
like a southern ER right now I feel like
we should be on a porch somewhere
drinking you know mint juleps but at the
end of the day we're going to get stung
and we have been stung and we've been
stuck in California we haven't been
stung elsewhere but at the end of the
day not to beat the metaphor to death
too much the end of the day I think that
we have we have we have we have asked
for a fight that we have now gotten
right and some of us are upset that that
fight has resulted in some some punches
and some black eyes and California is
one of them and the other piece of it
from and so I think strategically
marriage might not be the only fight we
want to have I think we want to pick
some fights that we know we can win so
that we can store up some energy for the
big fights right and marriage is
definitely big
the other piece of this is that within
the LGBT community marriage is not I
would argue the most important issue for
the broadest range of LGBT people that
for there are a lot of folks Employment
non-discrimination is more important
than marriage for a lot of folks
adoption rights are more important than
marriage for a lot of folks universal
health care is more important than
marriage for a lot of folks there are a
lot of things that are important they're
more important than marriage and I think
by focusing or overemphasizing marriage
as the sort of you know gem in the crown
of gay rights or LGBT rights we are
alienating a broad swath of folks within
our community right homeless trans youth
are not principally interested in
whether and getting married they're more
interested in being making sure they're
protected against you know all sorts of
street violence and all sorts of
discrimination so forth you know that
you know there are folks and communities
of color and poor communities all over
the country for whom marriage is
something that you know middle-class
white people live in the suburb want and
so I do think that by overemphasizing
marriage and by fixating on Prop 8 we do
more to break the bonds that we should
be strengthening in our community I
don't think that marriage is a winning
issue when we're when one of our goals
is to create as broad and multicultural
and multi class an LGBT community moving
forward politically